wow like with my mom I just see her
everywhere you know like I see her when
I go on a walk or I see her like all
these memories you know and I feel like
when she's gone she came back
into the Earth and I see her everywhere
three children without their mother
after what started with the missing
person's case and ended with murder many
times we report in the criminal case but
we don't often hear about the long-term
effects on the families Left Behind
eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy talks with the family trying to
cope with life without their loved ones
here in mourn and be sad like he wants
us to be sad ocean Simpson recalls words
from her mother's killer Cheryl and
beardall was just 34 years old when her
husband Phillip O'Reilly murdered her
was just anger she and her brother
Achilles say their stepfather also
abused them he wouldn't keep us in the
home he would not let us out O'Reilly
and beardall had a child together
beardall's sister Jessica canutulis says
that's part of the reason she felt like
she couldn't leave Philip told her that
he's always going to take one kid with
him then in 2020 beardle was reported
missing O'Reilly had concocted a lie
claiming she took off from their
Henderson home and left him with the
three children I'm not stupid you know
like
you're cleaning the whole house
smells like bleach in here
um
you you threw away your mattress and I
don't know it's it's kind of odd you
wouldn't you wouldn't let anyone
upstairs you know
like especially because I my bedroom was
upstairs too so O'Reilly was later
arrested police say he beat beard all
with a dog leash then from jail I knew
that something like that would happen
O'Reilly tried to hire a hit man to kill
ocean and achilles and their aunt and
uncle knutla and her husband who are
taking care of the three children
basically manipulated us with that
statement that if he goes to jail that
we would be hunted down at this time the
fort's point descends you in June
O'Reilly was sentenced to life in prison
after pleading guilty to murder you and
your brother seem so strong how do you
do that I think we get it from our mom
actually because she she was very strong
the court case is wrapped up while the
family continues to try to cope with the
trauma they also face some new struggles
O'Reilly claims he dismembered
beardall's body her remains have never
been found we can't get a death
certificate since ocean is 17 years old
custody will soon no longer be an issue
but for Achilles who's 14 and beardall's
now five-year-old daughter whose
identity we're protecting at the request
of the family canoodles says she and her
husband want to officially adopt them
and without a death certificate it's a
challenge I mean the adoption could have
been
easier I guess there's an option that
you can put her as abandonment but in
her memory there's no way she would have
abandoned those kids so we didn't felt
like it was right to do there are legal
fees and the cost of going from a
two-person home to a five-person
household she says she'd also like to
move from the house where O'Reilly tried
to have the family killed she tells us
money is tight and points to challenge
after challenge but she says it's all
worth it we get to raise these kids that
are such a blessing
um
and it's hard to do it without her
but
we live on through the memories and we
have all these memories of how amazing
she was Vanessa Murphy
who's now
Vanessa reached out to Clark County
about that death certificate a
spokesperson says it's only issued when
there are human remains unless there is
a court order the family would then need
to petition the Court to declare beard
all dead now Vanessa also contacted the
biological father of ocean and achilles
he will not agree to give up custody but
he will allow them to live with their
mother's family since they appear to be
doing well now we have a link to the
GoFundMe set up by Jessica canutilla at
8newsnow.com we also have that number
for the domestic violence hotline in
case you or a loved one need help